it's January there's nothing else going  on Christmas is over new year is over so  it's nice just to have something to go  out and have some fun the tactics  involved in the chariot racing is  actually quite technical you have to get  into the lead after the first Bend  because overtaking around the course is  actually quite hard so if you're in  second place going into the corner  you're going to be struggling it was  amazing it was really exciting it's  really hard work the other team  sabotages they had a big flag and it  came up and got stuck in her will and so  we had to stop and get the flag out and  we still won everyone's accidental go